welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dollamore host of the dollar
more daily on YouTube and the podcast I
doubt it
Congress today let's talk about
congressional committees specifically
let's
look at Great Duty and the work that
could be being done
by passing legislation to make the lives
of Americans better and easier
that is not what's taking place
Republicans have wanted power for so
long
they were willing to lie Steed and chill
uh lie steal and cheat as it were
to get it
and now that they're there it's chaos 24
7. it is Circus atmosphere 24 7. it's
getting nothing done
24 7.
Jim Jordan I mean and if you need any
more evidence of what the statement I
just made Jim Jordan is the Judiciary
chairman in the House of Representatives
Jim Jordan
and Matt Gates who's also a member of
the Judiciary Committee
offered up an amendment today and you
can you can judge whether you think this
is going to make your life better more
rich
easier I'll let you be the judge
he offered up an amendment that they
start every hearing of the Judiciary
Committee in the House of
Representatives by putting their hand in
their heart and reciting the Pledge of
Allegiance
this was the important work of Congress
today at least many minutes were taken
up by this debate
and rather than just go along with it
Democrats rightfully
push back on this
and we're going to talk about that but
for you know let me go off on a tangent
here look I served in the United States
Marine Corps for many years
I I don't understand
the Pledge of Allegiance I don't
understand
uh this this this attempted
indoctrination of our children of making
them recite this thing I know that you
can opt out of it but to to swear
allegiance to a piece of cloth
it it's very weird to me it's very
strange to me and for congress people to
be wasting taxpayer dollars trying to
get an amendment that they start every
session with the Pledge of Allegiance is
just their election it's insanity
and luckily David cisolini was there a
congressman from Rhode Island
to push back on this and offer his own
amendment that if you've participated in
an Insurrection or you're an
Insurrection apologist you don't get to
say
the Pledge of Allegiance watch this
thank you Mr chairman I um you know Mr
Isa just made a reference to how
important it is for us to display our
commitment to the Constitution and to
commit to defend it aggressively
so I'd like to offer an amendment to the
amendment uh adding in the second
paragraph where the chair May designate
an individual to lead the pledge of
allegiance to add the following language
provided however the pledge shall not be
led by an individual who supported an
Insurrection against the government of
the United States in any way
because I think if we adopt this
amendment then we will be truthful in in
representing that stating this pledge is
an affirmation of your defense of
democracy and the Constitution it's hard
to take that claim seriously if in fact
an individual who in any way supported
an Insurrection against the government
United States is allowed to leave the
pledge so I would ask Mr gates to accept
this friendly Amendment and I look
forward to supporting with a gentleman
yield I first asked Mr Gatesville
support the amendment
to make sure that someone who led an
Insurrection against the United States
doesn't make a mockery of the Pledge of
Allegiance and stand before this
committee with their hand over their
heart claiming to support the
Constitution Mr Cellini my concern would
be if your definition of an Insurrection
is objecting to electors then there
would be many Democrats on the committee
that wouldn't be eligible to lead the
pledge since so many that's not my
definition I mean the last Republican
president gets sworn in absolutely
projectors was George Herbert Walker
blaming Mike Thomas Gates I will allow
the chairman to determine whether or not
someone has participated in surrection
United States I think this language is
important with the gentleman further
yield I'm asking Mr Gates will you now
accept the amendment well I'm I'm
concerned that that you may be
disqualifying too many of your own
members Mr Sicily I'm not concerned
about that at all then agree to the
amendment
that's someone the right to stand before
the house Judiciary Committee and lead
the Pledge of Allegiance at a bare
minimum let's guarantee that that person
has not participated or supported or in
any way helped and overthrow of the
government of the United States with the
gentleman yield a simple proposition
got it this is a giant waste of time
I've previously stated that I still
think that but making the point is good
making the point that David cisolini is
making here is is a noble cause because
we need to point out hypocrisy where we
see it and especially in Congress we do
and that's a full-time job when you have
Republicans in leadership
to support
those who who attempted to overthrow the
United States government by way of force
by trying to delay the certification
by by violating the Constitution by
delaying a constitutionally mandated
certification of electoral voters
it flies in the face of this respect for
the Constitution you see a lot of these
goofballs who carry around in their
pocket a little a little pamphlet that's
the Constitution and they wave it around
and they act like they're they're
they're Noble Patriots don't tread on me
they say
yet they full-throatedly
some with Fists in the air and
solidarity like Josh Hawley supported
the Insurrection against the United
States
they knew what was taking place and they
supported it
so it's it's hypocrisy run a mock
for Matt Gates of all people to ask that
they recite the Pledge of Allegiance in
honor of our country as some
masturbatory patriotism because that's
what this is
they've watched their dear leader
literally hug and kiss the flag and they
believe that's the path to enlightenment
it's all just gross
but what would you expect when you got
Matt Gates and Jim Jordan in the mix
the other piece of uh Congressional
hearings today
involves a little bit of a prediction
that took place a few months ago by many
of the people who do what I do
and that is as soon as Marjorie Taylor
green gets on a committee it's going to
be chaos
and she's going to not earnestly take
the work seriously
she's going to be someone who's there to
create clips for Newsmax and Fox News
and oan
and she started off with the band
I will say this though it's very clear
that she's well she's obviously a dumb
dumb but she's out of practice having
not served on committees for so long
uh in her previous term
and
let me just set the stage for you she's
she's questioning Gene Daddario who's
the the Comptroller general of these
United States and uh and the head of the
the U.S government accountability office
and Marjorie Taylor Green's asking all
these just whacked questions
about whether or not covid dollars
relief money went to support or went to
fund CRT and then other things but let's
start with the the just the jackassery
of the concept of this question here's
Marjorie Taylor green fighting the good
fight
can you tell me uh how much how much
coveted cash went to CRT
CRT critical race Theory and education
it's it's a racist uh uh curriculum used
to teach children uh that somehow their
white skin is not equal to black skin
and other things in education yeah uh no
I do not know that but I do know that
there's Provisions that the federal
funds generally are not used they're
supposed to be used for curriculum oh
that's a statement oh Mr Darrow I have
to tell you in Illinois that they
received 5.1 billion
um at an elementary school there that
that used it for equity and diversity
um so it's it's being used for these
things uh Mr De Niro can you
foreign
I mean of all the summations that you
could hear uh that try to Define what
CRT critical race theory is that's one I
haven't heard that they teach that black
skin is somehow or white skin is not as
good as black skin
and then the claim that an elementary
school a single Elementary School in
Illinois received
5.1 billion dollars in covid relief to
teach CRT
that's one hell of a covid uh curriculum
if if you're asking me uh 5.1 billion
would fund hundreds of schools not just
a single Elementary School's curriculum
in this specific thing that they're
trying to fear-monger
critical race Theory one isn't being
taught in elementary schools
because it is a graduate level uh
critical theory
it is for law students it is not for
elementary kids and it's most certainly
not that black skin is better than white
skin or white skin isn't as good
as black skin or or uh yeah as as blacks
see it's this is so stupid it's even
difficult for I mean I am a bit of a
dum-dum myself but this is so stupid and
it's even difficult for me to even
recite
so the questioning went on she's very
concerned about covid dollars and where
they went where relief money was spent
um she she also is asking the same man
who's a very serious dude has a very
serious job about the funding with covid
dollars of drag queen Story Hour dinero
can you tell me how much money was given
to drag queens Story Hour
that I'm sorry could you repeat that
drag queen Story Time where where men
dress up as women and read confusing
books to Children first I thought you
said dry clean so I'm sorry uh no I
don't know the answer to either one of
those two oh we need to look into this
and I I urge you to do that um they uh
Bradberry Sullivan LGBT community center
in Pennsylvania received sixteen
thousand dollars uh for drag queen story
time uh from from coveted cash
um I think this is an issue that needs
to be looked into a lot of this money
went to things that should have never
gone to and I thank you so much and I
yield back the remainder of my time if
only she would permanently yield back
the remainder of her time I think
America would be better off
look if an lgbtq Community Center
received covid funds it's not
specifically earmarked for drag queen
Story Hour
which by the way no one is being harmed
by that where they're re they read
confusing books she says
look bring it in Marge bring it in just
because you're confused by a book
doesn't mean that book is inherently
confusing
she continued it's not just CRT the
dangers of CRT and it's not just
drag queen Story Hour it's also
talking about her own PPP loan she
wanted to get it on the record in case
it got brought up by someone else that's
all I can assume but she's denigrating
someone for taking PPP money while
admitting that she also took PPP money
it make it make sense watch this hey Mr
chairman I'd like to bring up something
that was brought up by one of our
Democrat colleagues on this panel about
Republican members of Congress taking
PPP loans I I never took one as a member
of Congress but as a business owner I
did take a PPP Loan in order to be able
to pay my employees and I'm so thankful
I was able to do that because they would
have lost their jobs and I think it's
important to recognize but the minority
um side of our our committee here is
having a witness on the next panel that
had said that she didn't or her or any
of her Affiliates take any federal
grants or contract tracks related to
this hearing's subject matter but in
fact as executive director of the
national employment law project they
took it they took over 825
000 in PPP loans from the SBA so that
that does need to be pointed out about
the next panel Witnesses uh here we are
a nation
and in her mind she just leveled a
devastating blow
remember this tweet from like August
where the White House put up all of the
different Congress people who were
maligning the Forgiveness of student
loans who took hundreds of thousands and
sometimes millions of dollars in PPP
loans
yeah this is a congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green had a hundred and eighty
three thousand five hundred four dollars
in PPP loans forgiven
so it is the height of hypocrisy it is
the height of stupidity and it is
um an aggrieved Republican who's looking
to take out their frustrations and
Vengeance on
uh Democrats I guess but through the
American people and also by not doing
their job they see they talk about fraud
waste and abuse so much it's a common
refrain but really the fraud waste and
abuse here in this case on this segment
is Marjorie Taylor green not doing her
job yet still getting paid to do it and
maybe
Marjorie Taylor green should take a page
out of the Playbook of Alexandria
ocasio-cortez because the same hearing
the very same hearing she was there to
set an example for Marjory Taylor green
and the rest of these nuts on how to
actually question and how to actually
investigate and how to actually do your
job of oversight
questioning the same man
AOC is actually getting to the bottom of
actual fraud waste and abuse that is
egregious and should be investigated
whether it's in a Republican state or
whether it's in a Democrat state
watch this
is there any methodology you can think
of that would just result in
Pennsylvania and New York and California
being under investigation by this
committee well I I would defer to the
committee I don't really know what their
their objectives were in that case and I
I don't think I understand yeah
um now I wanted to get into this report
um according to this report to prac for
example Arizona paid 1.6 billion dollars
to individuals uh to stolen identities
to get unemployment insurance benefits
Louisiana dispersed more than 1 million
to individuals after the date of their
death and in Kentucky
state employees applied for unemployment
benefits while still employed by the
state and were able to hack the state's
information management system and remove
holds on their own accounts and none of
these states
have been put under investigation by
this committee I find it very
interesting because as was stated at the
beginning the bipartisan nature of
oversight is what gives it its power
and what we are seeing are
investigations uh into and I believe
that that the methodology for these
three states is Highly Questionable and
I ask for this committee if we're going
to perform oversight then let's perform
oversight Congressional Democrats are
ready to perform that oversight and help
our constituents get the benefits they
need to pay their bills and I think that
there's no shortage of members of this
committee who are willing to stand up to
their own party when it's necessary but
I cannot for the life of me understand
why the majority would send these three
letters just to these three states that
leave us with no other conclusion that
there needs to be some rank partisanship
in this investigation committee
Republicans uh I ask you know if we're
going to start off let's do it right
that is a master class that should be
taken into account by every one of these
dum-dum Republicans and put into
practice in their own uh operation of
their job
the fact that Pennsylvania New York and
California are under the watchful gaze
of the uh the house oversight and
accountability committee yet Kentucky
the home state of the chairman of this
committee James Comer is
laughable
that
they were paying state employees who
were still working unemployment benefits
and allowed them and look
Kentucky has a Democratic governor
and what Alexandria ocasio-cortez is
saying here is it doesn't matter if
we're going to be investigating
corruption let's investigate corruption
let's let's investigate the misuse and
fraud and waste and abuse of taxpayer
dollars that were meant for a noble
purpose during a global pandemic that
rocked the planet
but instead they're ignoring Arizona
they're ignoring Louisiana they're
ignoring they're ignoring every other
state
the other 47 States and territories and
the District of Columbia where we have
no representation
again Republicans not doing their job
because they're not there to accomplish
anything other than chaos other than
investigations it's Benghazi Benghazi
Benghazi Benghazi Benghazi all over
again except they're using a different
word
because they're not there to accomplish
anything they're not there to get
anything done for the American people
and it's pointed out expertly
masterfully
by Alexandria ocasio-cortez
I am Jesse dollamore I'd love to have
you subscribe to my YouTube channel just
search my name Jesse dollar Moore follow
me on social media I am at Dollar Moore
on Instagram Twitter and Tick Tock and
you can listen to my twice weekly
podcast co-hosted by myself and Brittany
page it's called I doubt it and it's
everywhere that you find podcasts
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I want to welcome you back to the David
Pacman show I am Jesse dollar Moore
filling in for David while he is out
hopefully resting and relaxing this week
Let's Talk About Kevin McCarthy let's
talk about Congress in general and the
the budget battle that we're facing and
the the debt ceiling battle that we're
facing
we can set aside the fact that
Republicans uh approved uh an in the
debt ceiling fight they they went
through it and they approved a debt
selling increase for for three times
under Donald Trump When Donald Trump was
President three times no problem oh yeah
it's not a big deal that's it's the
responsible thing to do when there's a
republican in office
but when a Democrat is in office then oh
no no we we need to we're going to shut
down the government if you don't bend
and bow to our demands
again because it's not about governance
it's not what's best for the full faith
and credit of the United States of
America it's not about any of that it's
about scoring political points it's
about chaos in the system
and Kevin McCarthy was just at the White
House and
um had a meeting with Joe Biden
he comes out of the meeting and is
peppered with questions for several
minutes by reporters and there's one
question in in particular that I really
want to hone in on because one Kevin
McCarthy's
woefully inadequately uh suited for this
job he's not real bright he's not very
articulate and he just generally kind of
fumbles around in the dark for an answer
the second clip will really really
illustrate that but let's start with
this first question I don't know how
well you're going to be able to hear the
audio so I'll just I'll ask the question
then then you'll be able to piece it
together when you hear the reporter ask
it it's what credibility do
conservatives and Republicans have when
they talk about reducing the debt and
deficits when in the previous
administration when Republicans had
control of both the White House and
Congress they ran up the bill
and this there's no way to disagree with
the premise of these questions this is
fact
when Republicans have been in office
they run away deficits go crazy the
national debt soars
now these are metrics that you can argue
whether they're important or not I don't
generally think a large national debt
makes that much difference
but
let's set that aside we'll just set that
aside the fact of the matter is Donald
Trump with his irresponsible unpaid for
tax cuts wasn't able to fund the
government and every all the spending
that needed to be done and his tax cuts
resulted in they were promised that they
would be paid for they promised it would
spark the economy so much that uh it
would just be cash hand over fist into
the treasury
the fact of the matter the the the the
data the the the actual reality is that
there were one trillion and one and a
half trillion dollar deficits
one thousand billion dollar deficits
and one and a half uh and fifteen a
hundred billion dollar deficits every
year of Donald Trump's
presidency
making it so that Donald Trump is
responsible personally as his
administration for 25
of our overall national debt and the
Goof was only in office for four years
pales in comparison it makes Reagan's
Administration and the the wild rampant
spending looked like Child's Play
but let's let's get to this question
from the reporter and listen to Kevin
McCarthy's answer and uh we'll talk
about it on the other side
that's a great question
um when Republicans have control both
the White House in Congress ran up the
bill okay let's just go by the the sheer
facts of figures all right so
Republicans were in the majority for
eight years and then the Democrats came
in the majority for the last four years
so in the last four years the Democrats
have increased discretionary spending by
30 percent over 400 billion dollars when
the Republicans were a majority twice
that long the discretionary spending
didn't go up one dollar it went down 10
billion so I think that the credibility
lasts easily with the Republicans if you
want to argue about from a place where
the president the past president
um if you continue down the same path
this presidency will spend and put us in
debt much greater than before so look
I'm not in a place that I'm going to
point fingers I'm in a place of being
the Speaker of the House
my role right now is to make sure we
have a sensible responsible ability
to raise the debt ceiling but not
continue this runaway spending this is a
moment in time that for All American
households every family does this every
business does this every state
government every County government when
they have spent too much
take a little rain back look where waste
is at look where Investments would be
better and sit down and talk in an adult
fashion that's the conversation I just
had with the president and that's the
conversation I want to continue so we
can come to an agreement
why didn't you have those conversations
while Donald Trump was president
why didn't you identify those areas that
are now so important that you're willing
to shut down the government over them
Kevin McCarthy
and all of the ancillary nonsense that
you bring up doesn't defeat the points
that when Donald Trump was in office
prior to becoming president when he
spoke to Bob Woodward with the
Washington Post and said the audacious
claim that he was going to pay off the
entirety of the United States debt
inside of eight years
and instead jacked it up went crazy
spending not raising enough money into
the treasury through tax cuts
that by the way didn't Sunset they
sunseted for the middle class they
didn't sunset
for the rich
this just it's hypocrisy and it's excuse
making and he's stumbling and bumbling
and trying to find a point
and only Republicans fall for this
because it's
it's nonsense and it's propagated this
propaganda by right-wing media Outlets
now getting back to the point earlier
about how he is unfit to be speaker that
he's not qualified or capable of being
speaker listen listen there's a lot of
word salad politicians in Washington
many come to mind one not in Washington
maybe Chief among them is Sarah Palin
but there's a lot of them out there
George W Bush was famous for his word
salad
this sentence I challenge you
to
to explain to me in my feeble brain what
the hell he is talking about listen to
this I believe in hearing both
perspectives like anything else be it
business be it in family being in
relationships that you can find common
ground there's nothing in there but me
walking away that does not believe at
the end of the day we can come to an
agreement
foreign
did you
catch that because I sure didn't I have
no idea what he's talking about let's
read it again
there's nothing in there but me walking
away that does not believe at the end of
the day we can come to an agreement
there's nothing in there but me walking
away that does not believe at the end of
the day we can come to an a
agreement
like make it make sense
please it's not it's not a rhetorical
question please it's not a rhetorical
request please make it make sense
he's just not fit he's not ready
I mean that we we have many damaging
speakers of the house over the course of
the history of our country even more
modern times Newt Gingrich comes to mind
but they were articulate they could find
a complete sentence with with uh with
but one hand and and Kevin McCarthy is
just incapable
and it's uh it's going to hurt you it's
going to hurt America overall because
he's going to allow the the inmates to
run the prison he already is letting
that happen with Marjorie Taylor green
and while he's uh running over the White
House to to make a big to do about his
negotiation
nothing's getting done other than you
know some real damage that may be
irreparable
the other thing Kevin McCarthy did today
was not just involving going to the
White House and not speaking in complete
sentences that can be understood by
people who uh their native tongue is
English uh he was a prayer breakfast the
the the the the the the Gathering for
prayer and repentance
a Tony Perkins joint I guess
and it is a gathering of of Christian
nationalists and radicals and there were
over a dozen members of Congress there
today and I'm gonna play I'm gonna play
a couple of Clips here one
um
Kevin McCarthy went and actually gave a
prayer at this thing with members of
Congress republicans in Congress before
him doing his father God thing and and
really laying it on thick that he's some
holy devout righteous man of God and uh
give you a flavor for that then let's
move on to Andrew Brunson who's a
Christian nationalist preacher who is
just laying the the bigotry just amping
it up to 11. watch Kevin McCarthy give
his little prayer dear heavenly father
we come before you today
to seek your forgiveness
father we thank you for that forgiveness
we thank you for your love we thank you
for your grace
father I want to lift up these Faith
leaders from across the nation
father I want to thank you that we can
pray and seek your word and seek your
forgiveness in the Museum of the Bible
it's all a bit much look
this is not intended as as a mockery of
religion this is my faith tradition this
is what I grew up in is this this this
flavor of of evangelicalism
ultimately what is white Christian
nationalism
but to parade yourself out
praying to Jesus Christ while
jettisoning any adherence to the
philosophies of the actual man is just I
mean blasphemy comes to mind
sharing a stage the woman off to the
left there on your screen Mary Miller
is someone who has praised Hitler in
speeches right outside the United States
capital
but let's go to Andrew Brunson
who is giving a
just a a wild bigoted screed talking
about us living under and being ruled by
the rainbow flag
it's let's talk about it on the other
side watch this
I believe that we are in danger of
judgment as a nation especially because
we have become the primary corrupter of
the world
and particularly of Youth and children
our government and Corporation is
increasingly March under the rainbow
flag
we bully weaker and poorer countries to
come under that flag our University's
train millions of foreign students who
return to their countries with this
ideology our social media and
entertainment companies make it
attractive they promote they normalize
celebrate immorality
and there's no escaping them as a
blanket the world
their Godly mothers and fathers around
the world who fear our influence and
sometimes when I'm in a foreign country
I want to fall on my knees and repent
for what we are doing to these countries
to these people
Jesus said woe to the ones to the one
who causes others to sin
and he underlines us especially in
relation to the young whoever causes one
of these little ones to sin it would be
better for him if a millstone were hung
around his neck and he were drowned in
the depth of the sea
I hate to break it to you Andrew Brunson
gay people exist
and we're not marching uh our government
and corporations increasingly March
under the rainbow flag
gay people exist
and they are American citizens who have
rights
equal protection
as far as the 14th Amendment of the
Constitution
and for Kevin McCarthy to share the same
stage on the same day within this the
frame of a few minutes as this bigot is
alarming
this is the the political Battle of the
next eight to ten years maybe Beyond
because they're no longer quiet they're
no longer Whispering about being
Christian nationalists and again when
you hear Christian nationalists you
should automatically know that it is
white Christian nationalist because
these same people
who talk about the philosophies of Jesus
they don't want
equality for everyone they don't want
equity on a stage through education or
financial
um
assistance in this country
they want to prop up white supremacy
they want to oppress gay people they
want to strip away women's Reproductive
Rights
and if if you don't think that it's
important and you think that I'm just
rambling here about some prayer
breakfast
you need to pay a closer closer
attention to what is taking place
because this has been
a concerted effort a strategic effort
over the course of decades
when the religious right and the the
moral majority of Jerry Falwell
this is what they've led to this is what
they have planned and strategically
worked for over the course of 30 or 40
or 50 years
and they're getting their way they're
winning Roe v Wade was overturned
by a group of fanatical
religious nut bags who sit on the
Supreme Court
and it would be one thing if it was just
Andrew Brunson some guy you've probably
never heard of
but it's not just Andrew Brunson
Randy Weber
republican from Texas actually gave a
prayer here I'm going to play it for you
where he's sobbing and weeping about all
the millions of babies that we've killed
he's he's begging God for forgiveness
to put America back on the right path
at worshiping you we've taken God out of
the classroom
ignoring
the First Amendment of the Constitution
that Congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
but they want Jesus in the classroom
talk to little Muslim kids or little
Jewish kids or little atheist kids
so it's not just Andrew Brunson it is
members of Congress who have the power
to vote on legislation
who are there too
who are who are luxuriating in the
bigotry
watch Randy Weber
father you say in your word that unless
the Lord watches over the city
The Watchmen stay awake in vain
Lord we are a nation without a Rudder
address father we think we're so smart
we've kicked you out of schools we've
kicked prayer out we've kicked the Ten
Commandments and we've replaced the you
with drug-sniffing dogs with armed
police officers with metal detectors
Lord forgive us
father we've trampled on holy matrimony
Lord God we have killed so many babies
and we call them a choice and I remember
in Deuteronomy 30 19 Moses called Israel
to choose life so that we in all of our
descendants could live Lord our
descendants aren't living we're killing
them
in the world
father you also say in your word
that the borrower is slave to the lender
and Lord we have totally forgotten your
word and your precepts and we're 33
trillion dollars in debt
father we think we're so smart but Lord
please forgive us
please please put America back on the
right path to worshiping you father I
ask this through the blood of the Lamb
Jesus Christ amen
thank you
come on man
that guy gets to vote on legislation
that guy has an impact on your everyday
life
sobbing and wailing and gnashing of
teeth
weeping that he cannot
uh rule your life with his Christoph
fascism
that we've trampled on holy matrimony
because dudes can get married now with
what
it's all it's all
dangerous that will impact your life at
some point you might not feel it now but
in eight or ten years if this is ignored
we're going to be in a really
tough spot
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore I'd
love to see you follow me on social
media at dollymore on Twitter Instagram
and Tick Tock just at dollar more look
for me here on YouTube just search my
name dollar more daily I host uh just
about every day and I host a twice
weekly podcast called I doubt it that
you could find anywhere that you find
podcasts
see you there
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show welcome
back to the David pakman show I am Jesse
dollar more sitting in for David while
he is away
let's let's talk about a common refrain
a common turn of phrase that I use and
that is a dignity free performance
I am baffled by Republicans especially
election deniers out there who are
Shameless in their efforts and uh
and Shameless just in general about
their lies and their predictions and
everything else that just never comes
true and Mike pillow as David likes to
call him the my pillow goof Mike Lindell
he is maybe Chief among them
in the dignity free performance category
he was on he was on Jimmy Kimmel and it
was a remarkable like what is this guy
doing
sometimes when you watch him it's just
so perplexing that he's I think this
guy's a True Believer and then sometimes
he does other things I'm just I don't
understand it so let's let's put our
heads together here and watch this
Jimmy Kimmel stuffed him into a a fake
prop claw machine and made him do his
appearance on the show from the machine
and he went along with it
watch this
all the colorful unhinged characters
who've come to prominence in the
political era of Donald Trump our next
guest is probably the most enthusiastic
to help him overcome his debilitating
fear of machines we have installed him
inside a claw machine for his interview
tonight and joining us now from the
corner of Donkey Kong and Qbert the my
pillow guy Mike Lindell hello Mike
Timmy crumble is that you it's me
well Mike first question Mike is why do
you think people don't take you
seriously well you know I want to tell
you this Jimmy remember we were kids and
uh we questioned these carnival games
whether they were rigged or not yeah
right but when we spoke up back then we
didn't get sued did we no that's right
hey Mike get rid of that kid will you
give him a toy or something like that
there you go you got a winner it's a
regain a big game
Mike I know that you're distrustful of
machines now that you're inside one do
you feel differently no same thing
there's there are computers can be
rigged out there absolutely in elections
you know that did you ask Donald Trump
uh whether you should do this or not do
you run this sort of thing by him no I
didn't Jimmy I did this all my own I
wanted to be on your Shore you you you
know you kept telling me to come on but
you you know I see the monologue there
you said it's because to put me in here
because I was it wasn't vaccinated you
tricked me you didn't to be funny huh no
I didn't no I didn't want you in there
because you weren't vaccinated I don't
know to be honest I don't even remember
why I decided you should be in there
just don't you set it on yourself it
seemed like a good idea when it happened
I have to say I was very surprised when
you said you would do it but you know I
put it out there and so you said yes so
I you know I'm honoring that commitment
that I made on here
I mean ooh oof comes to mind cringe
comes to mind embarrassing humiliating
all of these terms what is he doing
he's not bolstering the case that he's
correct he's he he's he's creating a
situation where any credibility there
was none anyway that he may have had
it's just
like Dust in the Wind
bizarre to be sure
the other bizarre item that I want to
talk about here is George Santos again
sat down with aoan in a wide-ranging
interview very candid exclusive
interview with One America news and
he's not backing down
he apologizes out of one side of his
mouth and then says that uh he's a lot
of people are creating a fake narrative
that he faked his way to Congress or a
narrative that he faked his way there
ignoring all of the lies and he's taking
issue with it he's acting like it's
unfair how he's being treated
differently than any other member of
Congress and then finally a clip that
he's going to go ahead and extra step
now and double check and cross-reference
everything as though he needs to do that
with the details of his own life it's
all a bit much watch this first clip the
business of politics is littered at the
highest levels with deceit Miss true
Corruption of course and this is kind of
the time that you're now entering
politics so with that climate in mind
um
I guess where do you want to start and
your is your story your upbringing Maybe
well Caitlin look I come from a humble
beginning I've always said that I grew
up in abject poverty uh in Jackson
Heights in Queens in New York City uh
people like me aren't supposed to do big
things in life and when we do it
disrupts the system and I know that a
lot of people want to create this
narrative that I I faked my way to
Congress which is absolutely
categorically false I've worked hard
I've built ground up a career
um through experience and through
knowledge and through self-education and
you know I think it's amazing that I
have to sit here and be spoken down to
on a regular basis yet again by the
media
is George Santos really does he have the
gall the temerity and the the boldness
to to try to play this off as the system
coming down on him because he's the poor
lowly poor kid who isn't supposed to
make it
that the all the odds were stacked
against me
growing up poor in abject poverty
doesn't mean that you makes you a liar
take it from me I grew up exceedingly
poor on welfare free lunch all the works
the food stamps
it doesn't make you a liar
and here watch this Mr I've I've made
atonements I've made apologies I'm very
sorry I shouldn't have done what I did
here he is whining about the unfair
treatment that he's undergoing right now
now Angry
that's maybe you can say that I'm
passionate about all of this but anger
is just not something you I would think
is appropriate to describe me what
emotions do you feel right now you know
sad
sad that I've I put myself in this
predicament and and and I own up to it
but
I'm sad that the media has decided now
to Target my family
the media has decided to Target and
harass my friends anybody around me I
signed up for this job Caitlyn I signed
up for this not my my sister with my
five-year-old autistic niece or not my
husband at home with our dogs they
didn't sign up but you knew you knew
putting yourself and anyone that puts
themselves in the spotlight they know
what baggage that comes with
I have yet to see this be done to other
members of congress's family from the
death threats to the media harassment
pounding down the door leaving passive
aggressive notes all things I'd be glad
to share with you and if you can air the
stern this
I'll share you passive aggressive
threatening notes
a threatening note is not passive
aggressive
it's aggressive it's threatening it's
also a crime
so if you have evidence of journalists
threatening you
I go to the authorities
that there it is a federal crime
to threaten the life or threaten a
sitting member of Congress
do the good hard work George Santos
the media is not targeting you and
you're not being unfairly treated you
think you're the only member of I don't
believe you're getting death threats but
do you think you're the only member of
Have you listened to to Eric swalwell
and the voicemails he releases on his
Twitter
Cry Me a River you've created the media
frenzy you should be pleased as punch at
what has taken place
so enough
we get it
follow me on social media if you'd like
to leave me threatening and uh passive
aggressive notes I'm at dollamore on
Twitter Instagram and Tick Tock you can
find me here on YouTube uh dollar more
dailies the show that I host Daily
Dollar more see how it works
I also co-host a podcast with Brittany
page called I doubt it that you can find
at dollarmore.com or anywhere that you
find podcasts I'd love to see you there
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am once again Jesse dalamore filling in
for David while he is not here to do the
videos
uh right now we are facing a budget
battle we are facing a debt ceiling
increased battle that Republicans are
making hay over they are make trying to
score political points in an effort to
again create chaos and as much of it as
they can
had a guy named Dusty Johnson that's
apparently his real name Dusty Johnson
republican from South Dakota on and Jim
shudo is doing a valiant job a noble
effort here attempting to get
Congressman Dusty Johnson to just name
one one single program that he wants to
put on The Chopping Block to cut in an
effort to save the budget or whatever he
gives him multiple times multiple
chances to do this and the guy just flat
out refuses using some lame excuse about
not wanting to negotiate in public and
I'm not going to negotiate on TV the
same thing we're hearing Kevin McCarthy
say
but it's very easy if you want to be a
leader you want to be a congressman you
want to be someone who's in this budget
battle making responsible choices about
America and the spending of taxpayer
dollars you should be able to name at
least one program that you think needs
to be revamped relative to spending
watch this
so first on the budget demands of of
your party here what specific programs
are you putting on the table to cut
well that's not how a negotiation works
and in fact the law says that the
president needs to step forward with a
budget first his team is going to miss
their February deadline they say they're
not even going to get that done until
March so here's what I think is step one
today we need to have the president and
the speaker in the same room that's
going to happen and we need to have
President Biden agree that he will
negotiate Over The Reckless spending
that our country has been engaged in but
as you know the debt ceiling relates to
budgets already passed by congresses
including with Republican votes what are
the positions because a negotiation as
you know involves if you want to call it
that involves two sides presenting their
positions can you name a single program
that Republicans would be willing to cut
money from to make a deal but see I
think that's ridiculously unfair and
here's why the credit card bill comes to
our family we have maxed out our credit
cards now of course listen we're going
to pay that credit card bill we're
legally obligated to do so but rather
than force all of the onus on the
Republicans which I know you all love to
do what a responsible reasonable and
sensible family would do is sit down
together
[Music]
that's the law the law puts the onus on
Congress in the nation to pay its bill
but please go ahead is there a program
that you can name that you personally
would be willing to see money cut from
well yeah there are lots of programs but
that but the point is I'm not going to
negotiate against the Republican party
on CNN
the only thing that we're asking for
today is for President Biden to be
responsible sensible and reasonable and
being willing to come to the table and
negotiate so Mr thumb with ears Dusty
Johnson refuses to answer even one
single program and his little his cute
little family analogy it just doesn't
hold water
a family can't print money
budgets it's not a one-to-one comparison
and anyone who acts like it is is
pulling the wool over your eyes about
how simplistic it is
it's a complex macroeconomic system we
have here and budgets aren't like well I
got a mortgage I mean a credit card bill
and I got my grocery bill and we'll just
it's not how it works and he knows it
Mr thumbs with ears knows it
it is it is disingenuous to say the
least
little good news though let's finish
with this
wrong claim the outgoing chief of staff
for the White House gave a speech and it
made this uh they it's a video of him
giving the list of accomplishments of
this White House of this Administration
and uh it is when you hear it all at one
time it really does bring into Focus all
of the things that have gotten done even
with a Joe manchin and a Kirsten Cinema
standing in the way of some of the real
big progress things we could have gotten
done watch Ron Ron claim you've heard me
say this before but I never Tire of
saying it together we passed the largest
economic plan and most significant one
since FDR while managing the largest
land war in Europe since Truman
we passed the biggest infrastructure
Bill since Ike passed more judges than
any first year president than JFK and
the second largest health care bill
since LBJ the most significant gun
control Bill since Bill Clinton was
President and the largest climate bill
passed by any country at any time
anywhere on planet Earth all while
managing the worst Public Health crisis
any presidents faced since Woodrow
Wilson with the narrowest majority in
Congress of any new Democratic president
in a hundred years
[Applause]
massive it is impressive these things
did get done uh despite the efforts of
Republicans despite the efforts of the
independent now Kirsten Cinema and uh
Democrat
um from West Virginia Joe manchin does
he's a little out of breath there I mean
there's so many things to mention in so
little time he seemed out of breath it
reminds me it reminds me of that scene
from liar liar when Jim Carrey his
character gets pulled over by the cop
and then the cop just asked you know how
fast you were going or do you know why I
pulled you over
you know why I pulled you over depends
on how long you were following me
why don't we just take it from the top
here goes I sped I followed too closely
I ran a stop sign I almost hit a Chevy I
spent some more I failed to yield at a
crosswalk I changed lanes in the
intersection I changed lanes without
signaling while running a red light at
speeding
is that all no
I have unpaid parking tickets
yes
am I right or am I right Hey Ron clay
you know he's leaving the White House
and there's a he could if they make a
liar liar too he he can he could play a
role where he says a bunch of words real
quickly and
out of breath anyway uh that is it for
me uh thank you guys for tuning in uh
I'd love to have you connect with me on
social media and here on YouTube out
there on the social media landscape I am
at dollar more just about everywhere and
right here on YouTube just search my
stupid name Jesse dollar more or dollar
more daily thanks a lot
foreign